SEVEN NEVER MAIENSCHEIN NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OF THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY BLACKY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO C. R. TO SMITH. STONE
TEAM BALLOT AREAS THE ABUJA
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN. IMAM
YES SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD.
THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MORE
THE MOST MERCIFUL. I'M NOT A
GUARD. WE ASK YOU THAT YOU
BLESSED US WITH YOUR LIGHT.
THAT ELIMINATES OUR HEARTS AND
MINDS. THAT IN TURN ALLOWS US
TO MAKE DECISIONS. THAT
BRIGHTENS THE LIVES OF OTHERS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT NEED IT
THE MOST I MEAN. THANK YOU MOM
YES SIR WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER BRYANT PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS.
ONE NATION. UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL FOR SOME
REASON WAS ARGUMENT ON TUESDAY
MAY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
AGREEMENT AT SEVEN AM EST ON
OFFENSE BELONGS IN THE RIVER
SEVENTH DISTRICT DECIDING TO
FOLKS WHO PARK DANCE READING
FOR DAVID ABLE READING ROLL
CALL THE FOLLOWING PLACE ONE
WISHES. CHAO MOVES. MR MATH
SECONDS THE READ OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED. PORCH OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RAMOS
AND VALLADARES FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAN
SALAS AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. SAY ARE TELL. MEMBERS
VERY BRIEFLY I SEE MR STONE
HERE. TODAY IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE'S BIRTHDAY PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WISHING ASSEMBLY. AND MR
CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS JONES SAWYER
CARILLO FRIEDMAN AND LEAD TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE SB SEVEN
HUNDRED THE RUSSELL FOR THEIR
HEARING ON THURSDAY JUNE TWENTY
FOUR PENDING RE REFER ALL FROM
THE LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY ROOFS
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER BILLS FROM
SEVERAL POLICY COMMITTEES TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE LIST OF THE
BILL SAYS AT THE DESK AND I
WOULD ASK THE READING CLERK.
READ THE BILLS AT THIS TIME.
SEPARATING SENATE BILL THIRTY
THREE CINEMA ONE OF REASONABLE
TO THIRTY THREE SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY EIGHT SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY NINE SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY CENTRAL THREE SIXTY SEVEN
SENATE BILL THREE FOUR CYNICAL
FOR ONCE IN A BILL FOR
SEVENTEEN SYMBOL FOR FORTY
THREE SUITABLE FOR FIFTY FIVE
SYMBOL FOR FIFTY EIGHT SENATE
BEFORE SIXTY EIGHT SENATOR
FORTY SEVEN CENTRAL FORTY NINE
SENATE BILL FIVE OH FIVE
SUITABLE FIVE TWENTY NINE
SIMPLE FIVE SIXTY ONE SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY SEVEN CYNICAL
FIVE NINETY FOUR SENATE BILL
FIVE NINETY NINE SIX SENATE
BILL SIX BILLION CYNICAL SIX
FOR THE FORESEEABLE SIX FORTY
SEVEN. SENATE BILL SIX FORTY
NINE SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY
THREE SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY
EIGHT CYNICAL SEVEN OH SEVEN
SIMPLE SEVEN THIRTEEN SYMBOL
SEVEN TWENTY NINE TO THE BILL
SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT SENATE BILL
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE SIMPLE
SEVENTY TWO AND SENATE BILL
SEVEN NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER BOWMAN WITH. AND SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
CORKERY. SENATE BILL SEVENTY
ONE FOUR THIRTY SIX AND A JOINT
RESOLUTION ONE OF THE MINUTES
IN ABOUT THIRTY FIVE MINUTES
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY IN
CYNICAL SIX SIXTY WITHIN
MINUTES. ALL BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ. AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. WE ARE MOVING
TO. ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
FILE ITEMS NINE THROUGH ELEVEN
PASS RETAIN. WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE. THIS IS
MISS CLARK SILVA FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE ACR NUMBER. ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SOLUTION BORN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KIRK SILVA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO TAEKWONDO
DAY. MS CLARK SILVA ON THE
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
RELATED TECH TAEKWONDO DAY IN
CALIFORNIA OFFICIALLY DEVELOPED
AS A UNIFIED STYLE OF MARTIAL
ARTS IN THE NINETEEN FIFTIES
THE ROOTS OF TAEKWONDO STRETCH
BACK NEARLY FIVE THOUSAND
YEARS. TAEKWONDO BEGAN AS A
DEFENCE MARTIAL ART CALLED
SIBUK OR TAI KWON HAN AND
DEVELOPED AS A WAY OF TRAINING
BODY AND MIND. TAEKWONDO
CULTIVATE CULTIVATES MENTAL
STRENGTH AS WELL AS PHYSICAL
FITNESS AND TEACHES STUDENTS TO
USE THE KNOWLEDGE AND INTERNAL
POWER TO FOLLOW THE TENETS OF
COURTESY INTEGRITY PERSEVERANCE
SELF CONTROL AND SPIRIT. DURING
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
QUARANTINES HAVE HAD AN IMPACT
ON MENTAL HEALTH OF CHILDREN
AND ADULTS. I CUANDO IS KNOWN
TO BENEFIT MENTAL HEALTH
THROUGH INCREASED CONFIDENCE
AND IMPROVE SELF ESTEEM FOCUS
CONCENTRATION LEVELS SELF THIS.
SELF DISCIPLINE AGILITY AND
REFLEXES MY OWN SON JACK RYAN
QUIRK STARTED TAEKWONDO AS A
THIRD GRADER CONTINUE TAKING
TAEKWONDO WELL INTO HIGH SCHOOL
ACHIEVE THE STATUS OF A BLACK
BELT AND THEN NOW IS OFF TO
HASTINGS COLLEGE WHICH I THINK
IS BECAUSE OF THAT FOCUS FROM
TAEKWONDO. ACR SPEAKS TO THE
RICH HISTORY AND BENEFITS OF
TAEKWONDO WHICH ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS OF ALL AGES RACES
CREEDS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA TO
BUILD STRONG CHARACTER PURSUE
SELF FULFILLMENT THROUGH GOOD
DISCIPLINE AND IMPROVE PHYSICAL
AS WELL AS MENTAL HEALTH BY
PRACTICING TAEKWONDO. MEMBERS
WE SHOULD ALL PRACTICE
TAEKWONDO I THINK WE HAVE
BETTER MENTAL HEALTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON ACR ONE AND REQUEST
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS. THANK YOU AS QUICK
SILVA DR CHOI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SPEAKER
AND THE MEMBERS TODAY I RISE SO
AS A PROBLEM DON'T DON'T ALSO
OVER A C. R. ONE WHICH
RECOGNISES UP TIMBRE FOURTH THE
ASSET TAG WINDOW DAY. ACR ONE
RACES SO AWARENESS ALL ABOUT
THE HISTORY OF ATTACK ONE GOAL
AS A TRADITIONAL KOREAN MARTIAL
ART TO AS WELL- SO RECOGNIZES
SO THEY'LL FISCAL ENTITLEMENT
MENTAL HEALTH BENEFITS IT.
BRINGS TO OUR PRACTITIONERS. AB
ONE THOUGH IS THE AUTOBUS THAT
ARE NOT THE ORIGIN AND IT IN.
TEN NEWS TALK OR SMASH IT WITH
BEAT. ONE IMPLIES A PUNCHING
LARA DESTROYING WITH THE HANDLE
HANDLE A FIST AND THE TOLL MAN
SO AWAY OR ON OUR TO. R. MYSELF
WELL YOU MAY KNOW- LOS YOU MAY
NOT KNOW WHEN ALL IS SO YOUNG I
WAS ATTACK WINDOW INSTRUCTOR
WITH THE DOOR JOHN AND ON ALSO
ARE A- TAUGHT AT THE HENDERSON
STATE UNIVERSITY IN THE FISCAL-
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT THE- OF
FULL CREDIT. AND ALSO PRODUCED
A ALL BLACK PATTERSON SO OUR
WAY OF MY BLACK BELT ARE EVERY
DAY AND I'M SURE THEY ARE ALL
ON SOME BLACK BELT ATTACK WHEN
THE HOLDERS SO ON THE FLOOR
MAYBE WE CAN FORMER TECH
WENDELL BLACKMAN'S CLUB. IT'LL
BE QUITE INTERESTING AND I'M
INTERESTED IN NOT HAVING SOME
DAY SOME DEMONSTRATION OF THE
TECH ONE THOUGH- WHEN NOT A
TIME COMES AROUND I ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME IN SUPPORT OF WHAT IS
YOUR ONE- DECLARING SEPTEMBER
FOURTH AT A. SUBSEQUENT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOCKS CHOI.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. THIS QUESTION WAS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
RIGHT. VERSUS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLARK
WELL. CULTURAL THEIR SIXTY
EIGHT CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. OPPOSED
SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. THIS IS
FILE I'M THIRTEEN. ACR FIVE AND
MISTER MATHIS CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
RELATIVE TO VETERANS. MISTER
MATHIS YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT ACR FIVE WHICH WILL
COMMEMORATE THE SEVENTY FIFTH
YEAR OF AMVETS. THIS MEASURE
WOULD COME IN THE EVENTS
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA ON ITS
SEVENTY FIFTH YEAR PROVIDING
BENEFITS AND SERVICES TO OUR
VETERANS. FOR EXAMPLE THE
AMVETS WELCOME HOME PROGRAM
OPERATES FOR THRIFT STORES IN
FRESNO LONG BEACH THE HILLTOP
AND SOUTHERN AREAS OF SAN
DIEGO. THE WELCOME HOME PROGRAM
HAS MADE MORE THAN FIVE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
SUCCESSFUL FURNISHINGS AND
HOUSEHOLD ITEM DELIVERIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SINCE ITS
START. IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE.
FURTHERMORE IN ISSUE WHICH I
KNOW FIRST HAND. FROM MY FORMER
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN ARMS IS
AMVETS TACKLING VETERAN SUICIDE.
IN TWENTY TEN EVENTS NOTED THE
UNIMAGINABLE NUMBER OF VETERANS
COMMITTING SUICIDE AND BEGAN A
CAMPAIGN CALLED TWENTY TWO
EVERY DAY TO HELP VETERANS AND
OTHERS TO RECOGNIZE THE SIGNS
OF SUICIDE. BRING AWARENESS OF
THE HIGH RATES OF SUICIDE AMONG
WOMEN VETERANS AND EXPLORE THE
COSTS OF SUFFERING AND FEELINGS
OF HOPELESSNESS WITHIN OUR
VETERANS COMMUNITIES. SINCE
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE ADVANCES
EGGS. COMMITTED LEADERSHIP
ADVOCACY AND PROVIDED SERVICES
FOR CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES INCLUDING
VETERANS HOMES IN NUMEROUS
OUTREACH PROGRAMS. FOR SEVENTY
FIVE YEARS THE AMVETS
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN GIVING BENEFITS AND
RESOURCES TO THEIR FELLOW
VETERANS AS WELL AS PLAYING AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE CIVIC
LIFE. OF THEIR COMMUNITIES.
MEMBERS I DID ASK MY TEAM. TO
PASS AROUND TO YOUR OFFICES
THESE EVENTS TWENTY TWO A DAY
SUICIDE BRACELETS I HOPE THEY
GOT AROUND TO ALL OF YOU.
MEMBERS THIS RESOLUTION.
RECOGNIZES AND COMMEMORATES THE
HARD WORK THE DEDICATION THE
VITAL ROLE THAT AMVETS HAS IN
ADVOCATING FOR OUR VETERANS.
COMMUNITY IN SUPPORTING. THESE
BRAVE SERVICE MEN AND WOMEN
MEMBERS ASK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE RESOLUTION.
MISTER MATHIS WOULD LIKE. CLICK
LIBERAL. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. CO
AUTHORS ON A C. R. FIVE. CLERK
WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE
SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. IS HAVE IT.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. THIS
IS FILE ITEM FOURTEEN ACR
EIGHTY TWO BY MISTER COOPER.
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
GRAMMAR SOLUTION EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO JUNETEENTH.
THANKS COOPER EMAIL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY'S
I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS TO CELEBRATE MORE THE
MOST MOMENTOUS OCCASIONS IN
AMERICAN HISTORY AND THE OLDEST
AFRICAN AMERICAN HOLIDAY WELL
THIS YEAR JUNE NINETEENTH MARKS
THE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY SIXTH
ANNIVERSARY OF JUNETEENTH.
WOULD BE THE FIRST YEAR THAT
JUNETEENTH BE RECOGNIZED AS A
FEDERAL HOLIDAY CONGRESS
APPROVED A BILL YESTERDAY AND
PRESENT BONDS WITH BACK TO SIGN
IT INTO LAW LATER TODAY.
JUNETEENTH SYMBOLIZES FREEDOM
CELEBRITY ABOLISHMENT OF
SLAVERY AND REMINDS ALL
AMERICANS THE SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS TO OUR SOCIETY TODAY
WITH ACR EIGHTY TWO WE HONOR
REFLECT ON THE SIGNIFICANT ROLE
THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE
PLAYED IN OUR HISTORY AND HOW
THEY'VE BEEN RICH SOCIETY. FOR
THEIR STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO
PROMOTING UNITY AND EQUALITY
JUNETEENTH CELEBRATIONS ARE A
TIME TO REMEMBER REFLECT AND
PAY TRIBUTE TO THOSE AFRICAN
AMERICANS WHO FOUGHT SO LONG
AND WORKED SO HARD TO MAKE THE
DREAM OF EQUALITY AND FREEDOM A
REALITY. THIS JUNETEENTH IS NOT
PERTINENT TO EDUCATE THE
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY OUR YOUTH
AND COMMEMORATE THE INTO
SLAVERY IN THE UNITED STATES
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORT OF
ACR EIGHTY TWO TO CELEBRATE
JUNETEENTH. UNLIKE. THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISS COOPER MISTER
BRIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR
EIGHTY TWO. AS A MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. AND
IS THE ONLY MEMBER OF THE
CAUCUS ORIGINALLY BORN IN TEXAS
OF THIS HOLIDAYS EXACTLY
SPECIAL FOR ME THANK YOU THE
OLDEST BLACK HOLIDAY IN
AMERICA. AND I'M GLAD THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS DECIDED
TO RECOGNIZE IT I'M HONORED
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
TAKING UP THIS RESOLUTION I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL. THANK
WHICH BRAND MYSTERY THAT'S YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I AM HONORED TO
RISE ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR
EIGHTY TWO WHICH CELEBRATES
JUNETEENTH AND INVALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS TO OUR GREAT STATE.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR CENTER
TELEGRAM TO CESA CHAVEZ IN
WHICH HE STATED OUR SEPARATE
STRUGGLES ARE REALLY ONE A
STRUGGLE FOR FREEDOM OUR
DIGNITY AND FOR HUMANITY. DR
KING'S REMARKS CAME ON THE
HEELS OF THE HISTORIC PASSAGE
OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR WHICH
OUTLAWED DISCRIMINATION BASED
ON RACE AND COLOR. LIKE AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THE SOUTH MEXICAN
AMERICANS IN THE SOUTH WEST
ALSO FACED RACIST POLICIES THAT
KEPT MEXICAN AMERICAN VOTERS
OUT OF VOTING BOOTHS SCHOOLS
AND OTHER PUBLIC. SPACES
SEGREGATED. THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT A DIRECT RESULT OF THE
UNWAVERING ADVOCACY OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS HELP BRING OUR
COUNTRY CLOSER TO THE PROMISE
OF BEING A NATION WITH JUSTICE
FOR ALL OF US REGARDLESS OF THE
COLOR OF OUR SKIN. I SHARED
STRUGGLES OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND LATINOS REMAIN AS EVIDENCED
BY THE OVER REPRESENTATION OF
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITIES IN
AMERICA'S PRISONS THE FREQUENT
MURDER OF UNARMED BLACK AND
LATINO MEN AT THE HANDS OF
POLICE. AND THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT THE
COVERT NINETEEN IS HAVING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES THE FIGHT FOR
TRUE EQUALITY IS FAR FROM OVER.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON ACR
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU THREE OF
US MR WARD. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE LGBTQ CAUCUS I
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EASY ARE EASY TO
JUNETEENTH IS A CELEBRATION OF
THE END OF SLAVERY IN THE
UNITED STATES MARKING THE DAY
JUNE NINETEENTH EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FIVE IN WHICH A GROUP OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN GALVESTON
TEXAS LEARNED THAT THE CIVIL
WAR WAS OVER AND THAT THEY WERE
NOW FREE. WE NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE DAY HONOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
CULTURE AND RECOMMIT OURSELVES
TO THE CAUSES OF SOCIAL JUSTICE
ADVANCEMENTS IN THE LGBTQ
EQUALITY SPACE HAVE COME AS A
DIRECT RESULT OF THE WORK OF
BLACK LGBTQ ACTIVISTS AND THERE
ARE MANY INFLUENTIAL ACTIVISTS
THAT HAVE HELPED TO ENRICH OUR
LIVES JAMES BALDWIN ONE OF THE
GREATEST WRITERS OF THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY. AUDREY LARD
A SELF DSCRIBED BLACK LESBIAN
MOTHER WARRIOR POET MARSHA P.
JOHNSON A BLACK TRANS WOMAN
INVOLVED IN THE STONEWALL RIOTS
IN BAYARD RUSTIN THE CASE EQUAL
RIGHTS LEADER WHO ORGANIZED THE
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE MARCH ON
WASHINGTON AND WE ARE COMMITTED
TO LIFTING UP THE BLACK LGBTQ
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY THE BLACK
TRANS COMMUNITY IN AN EFFORT TO
END ALL FORMS OF OPPRESSION THE
CELEBRATION OF PRIDE MONTH AND
JUNETEENTH ARE CONNECTED AND WE
HOPE EVERYONE COMES TOGETHER TO
CELEBRATE OUR INTERSECTIONAL
HISTORY I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
NEC ARE EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER WARD DR WEBER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. ON BEHALF OF
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
I RISE AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR IN
SUPPORT OF ACR EIGHTY TWO. MANY
OF US IF NOT ALL OF US ON THIS
FLOOR ARE AWARE OF THE HISTORY
BEHIND THE CELEBRATION OF
JUNETEENTH. THAT THE DESPITE
THE FACT THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION WENT INTO EFFECT
JANUARY FIRST EIGHTEEN SIXTY
THREE. WHICH ENDED SLAVERY IN
THE CONFEDERATE STATES. THE
SLAVES IN TEXAS WERE NOT
INFORMED OF THIS INTO OVER TWO
YEARS LATER. IN THE DISCUSSIONS
OF SLAVERY AND THE CIVIL WAR
THE ROLE OF BLACK WOMEN THAT
THEY PLAYED IN A PATH TO
FREEDOM IS OFTEN OVERLOOKED.
WOMEN SUCH AS HARRIET TUBMAN
SOJOURNER TRUTH. MARY ELIZABETH
BOWSER AND MERRY TO VESTRY TO
NAME A FEW. OPERATED A
SURPRISED SCOUTS CURRIER'S AND
GUIDES FOR THE UNION ARMY.
THESE WOMEN WHO KNOW FIRST HAND
THE EVILS OF SLAVERY CREATED A
LEGACY OF STRENGTH AND
PERSEVERANCE AND A STRONG
FOUNDATION UPON WHICH MANY HAVE
STOOD FOR GENERATIONS TO COME.
THIS LEGACY IS STILL FELT IN
THIS NATION TODAY WHEN WE LOOK
AT BLACK WOMEN SUCH AS STACEY
ABRAMS MAXINE WATERS. AMANDA
GORMAN POLICIA GARZA PATRICE
CULLORS AN OPEL CEMENTING ONCE
AGAIN TO JUST NAME A FEW.
THROUGH WORDS AND ACTIONS THEY
ARE STILL FIGHTING FOR THE FULL
MEASURE OF FREEDOM. SO TODAY AS
WE EMBRACE AND CELEBRATE
JUNETEENTH AND AWAIT FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO SIGN S. FOR
SEVENTY FIVE INTO LAW MAKING
JUNETEENTH NATIONAL
INDEPENDENCE DAY OUR NEWEST
FEDERAL HOLIDAY. LET US NOT
FORGET THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
BLACK WOMEN HAVE PLAYED AND
CONTINUE TO PLAY IN THE NEVER
ENDING PURSUIT OF ACHIEVING
AMERICA'S PROMISE OF LIBERTY
AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A C. R. EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR WEBER.
MISTER MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER CAUCUS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR EIGHTY
TWO. THIS WEEKEND. TO CELEBRATE
JUNETEENTH I'M GOING TO THE
BEACH. BRUCE'S BEACH. AS MANY
OF YOU MAY KNOW AND I WANT
EVERYONE TO KNOW ABOUT THE
HISTORY OF BRUCE'S BEACH IN MY
DISTRICT AND BEAUTIFUL
MANHATTAN BEACH. MORE THAN A
HUNDRED YEARS AGO. WILLOW AND
CHARLES BRUCE BLACK BUSINESS
OWNERS RAN A SUCCESSFUL SEASIDE
RESORT. ONE OF ONLY TWO.
BEACHES AT THE TIME IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHERE BLACK
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WERE
WELCOMED FOR A DAY AT THE BEACH.
OTHER BLACK RESIDENTS CAME TO
MANHATTAN BEACH INVESTED AND
BOUGHT PROPERTY IN MANHATTAN
BEACH. ADDRESSES BEACH BECAME A
DESTINATION FOR BLACK FAMILIES.
UNTIL SOME OF THE WHITE
NEIGHBORS STARTED TO COMPLAIN.
AND THE CITY FOLLOWED BY
CONDEMNING BRUCE'S BEACH AND
TAKE IN THE LAND FROM THE BRACE
FAMILY THROUGH EMINENT DOMAIN.
NOW I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS HISTORY
BECAUSE IN A COUPLE OF WEEKS WE
WILL BE VOTING ON AN IMPORTANT
BILL. SENATE BILL SEVEN NINE
SIX. BUT I'M PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF. THAT WILL HELP
RETURN THIS BEAUTIFUL
OCEANFRONT LAND. TO THE
DESCENDANTS OF WILLOW AND
CHARLES BRUCE. SO HAPPY
JUNETEENTH EVERYONE LET'S GO TO
BRUCE IS BEACH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI MISTER
NAZARIAN. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE C. R. EIGHTY TWO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS THANK
YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM ELK
GROVE FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE FORWARD.
TODAY WE RECOGNIZE AND
CELEBRATE THE LIBERATION OF
THOSE WHO HAD BEEN ENSLAVED IN
THE UNITED STATES. WE HAVE SOME
DARK HISTORY IN THE US. BUT IT
IS VITAL THAT WE COMMEMORATE
THEM AND ALWAYS REMEMBER THESE
HISTORICAL POINTS OF INFLECTION.
THOUGH THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION OFFICIALLY
OUTLAWED SLAVERY IN TEXAS AND
OTHER STATES THAT STILL
ENSLAVED AFRICAN AMERICANS
RACISM DID NOT AND- JUNETEENTH
REMINDS US OF THE FIRST STEPS
WE TOOK TOWARDS EQUALITY AND
JUSTICE. HOWEVER WE SHOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT EVEN THOUGH
WE'VE COME A LONG WAY. WE STILL
HAVE SOME WAYS TO GO. WE STILL
WITNESS DEBATE AND FIGHT
AGAINST CONTINUED ACTS OF
DISCRIMINATION INEQUALITY AND
RACISM INCLUDING MAKING IT
DIFFICULT TO VOTE IN THIS DAY
AND AGE. LET'S NOT FORGET
COLLEAGUES WHILE IT'S WONDERFUL
TO CELEBRATE. AND IN A POSITIVE
LIGHT CAST THE PROGRESS WE'RE%
MAKING. IN ONE HAND ON THE
OTHER HAND WE SHOULDN'T BE
TAKING VOTING PRIVILEGES OR
RIGHTS NOT EVEN PRIVILEGES I'M
SORRY VOTING RIGHTS AWAY. FROM
THOSE THAT NEED IT MOST. EACH
TIME AN IMPORTANT MEASURE LIKE
THIS IS BROUGHT FORWARD WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO COMBAT THESE
IGNORANT ACTS AND MUST NEVER
STOP HAVING THESE DISCUSSIONS
AND DEBATES. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANKS MISTER NAZARIAN
MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I UP ALWAYS ASKED WHY
DO WE BRING THESE INCIDENTS UP
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND I'M A
PROPONENT THAT HISTORY TEACHES
US AND IF WE JUST REFUSED TO
PULL THE SCAB OF RACISM OFF TO
EXPOSE IT TO EVERYONE. THEN WE
WILL HEAL AND WE WILL FORGET.
THE PAST THAT HAD BEEN DONE WE
MUST NOT REPEAT THE INJUSTICES
AND MISTAKES. IF WE HIDE THEM
FROM EVERYONE ELSE. THE IDEAS
FROM HISTORY THAT THIS COUNTRY
FOR EXAMPLE. THAT THE EUROPEAN
COLONIZERS THAT CAME HERE WITH
THE FIRST ONES HERE WHILE THE
NATIVE AMERICANS WHO WERE HERE
FIRST WORD NOR. THE FACT THAT.
THERE WAS A BLACK WALL STREET.
ECONOMIC HUB OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY THAT WAS
BURNED TO THE GROUND. BECAUSE
THEY WERE SUCCESSFUL
ECONOMICALLY. WE MUST CONTINUE
TO REMEMBER WHY WE HAVE THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT BECAUSE SEEMS
LIKE OTHERS DO NOT EITHER ONE
OR BRING IT BACK IN EXTENDED OR
JUST FORGET ABOUT IT. WHAT
PEOPLE WANT TO CONTINUE TO DO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO JIM CROW LAWS.
THAT WE THOUGHT WERE GONE BUT
IF WE LOOK AT HISTORY AND LOOK
AT WHAT'S BEING DONE IN OTHER
STATES WE KNOW THEY'RE TRYING
TO BRING IT BACK. WE NOTE. THAT
A WHITE LIE. CAN KILL AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE CHARGE OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT LIKE EMMETT TILL.
AND IN HIS LATER HAVE RECANTED.
BUT HE'S STILL DEAD. THE REASON
WHY WE BRING THINGS UP LIKE
JUNETEENTH. IS BECAUSE ABRAHAM
LINCOLN DID EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION IN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY SECOND EIGHTEEN SIXTY
TWO. HE IT ENACTED IT IN. ONE
ONE EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE. AND
IT WASN'T UNTIL THE THIRTEENTH
AMENDMENT THAT ALL STATES. AND
ONE THIRTY ONE EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FIVE AND EVEN THEN. THE STATE
OF TEXAS STILL IGNORED AND WE
DIDN'T GET OUR FREEDOM MY
PEOPLE IN TEXAS MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS IN TEXAS ONE FREE UNTIL
JUNE NINETEENTH EIGHTEEN SIXTY
BY. THE REASON WANNA KEEP
REMINDING PEOPLE ABOUT
JUNETEENTH TEAM IS BECAUSE
JUSTICE IS DELAYED. IT WAS
DELAYED THEN AND CAN BE DELAYED
NOW IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE THAT IT HAPPENS
IMMEDIATELY. WE MUST ALWAYS
KEEP REMINDING OURSELVES OF THE
PAST WE DON'T WANT TO REPEAT IT
WE'RE DEALING WITH IMMIGRATION
ISSUES. THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
HOW CHILDREN ARE TREATED AT THE
BORDER. WE MET WE GOT TO WORK
REAL HARD TO MAKE SURE IT
DOESN'T TURN INTO WHAT MY
PEOPLE EXPERT EXPERIENCE WITH
FAMILIES BEING. TORN APART. IF
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT THE
VOTING RIGHTS. THAT PEOPLE DIED
FOR NINETEEN SIXTIES. BETTER
NOW BEING RIPPED APART IN
SEPARATE STATE ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY WE NOW KNOW WE NEED TO
FIGHT EVEN HARDER. TO MAKE SURE
WE CAN PRESERVE THOSE VOTING
RIGHTS. FROM A PRACTICAL
STANDPOINT JUST FROM A
PRACTICAL STANDPOINT. IF WE
ENACT A LAW HERE ON THIS FLOOR
IN SOME COUNTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DECIDES IT DOESN'T
WANT TO ENACTED FOR TWO YEARS
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL. HOW WOULD
YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT COUNTY IF
THEY DELIBERATELY WOULD NOT
ENACT A LAW THAT WE ENACTED ON
THIS FLOOR. THAT'S WHY WE TALK
ABOUT THE C. R. EIGHTY TWO
THAT'S WHY WE KEEP BRING IT
BACK JUNE TWO. JUNETEENTH
BECAUSE THE LESSONS FROM THAT
TIME. ARE STILL PREVALENT RIGHT
NOW. AND IF WE ARE NOT
AVAILABLE USE THAT COLLOQUIAL
WOKE TO WHAT'S HAPPENING AND TO
DO THE RIGHT THINGS. THEN
HISTORY WILL REPEAT ITSELF. AND
IT'LL BE ON US. BECAUSE WE LET
IT HAPPEN. WE NEED TO SUPPORT
ACR EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU
RESTAURANTS WHERE. SAY NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION. ON
THE RESOLUTION MISTER COOPER
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I DON'T THINK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS AND MAKE NO MISTAKE
THIS IS A MOMENTOUS TIME IN OUR
COUNTRY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR.
WILL BE OPEN FOR CALL AUTHORS.
THIS COOPER'S ASSET FOR SHALL
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION CO
AUTHORS AND I SEE OUR EIGHTY
TWO. THIS IS CO AUTHORS. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
CLICK WELL CULTURAL
THEIR SIXTY A CO AUTHORS AT IT
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. A POST SAY NAY. YES
HAVE IT RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO THE
SECND A CONSENT CAENDAR THERE
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR A VOTE WILL FIRST
TAKE OF THE RESOLUTIONS THAT
ARE ON CONSENT FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ADDING CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. CLERK WILL NOW OPEN
THE ROLE TO ALLOW ANY MEMBER TO
ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE
RESOLUTION. THE CLERK WILL READ
THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY CURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US AND OTHERS
RELATIVES CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
SAY. SEMI CURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KALRA AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE INTERNATIONAL
DAY OF YOGA. HOUSE RESOLUTION
FORTY FOUR BY SOME MEMBER WORK
RELATIVE TO SEE SCIENTISTS AND
HOUSE RESOLUTION FORTY FIVE BY
SIMPLY REMOVING MILITANTS AND
EXCELLENT. MICHAEL PHOSPHOR ME
HYDROPHOBICITY. MERE AWARENESS.
CLARKEN ALBUM THE ROLE. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. ON THE CONSENT
RESOLUTIONS. ALL MEMBERS BETTER
DESSERT ABOUT MEMBERS IF YOU
WISH TO ADD YOUR NAME AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE RESOLUTION PLEASE
VOTE. AT THIS TIME. THE LERK
WILL CLOSER ROLE THEY'RE SICK
THEY'RE SEVENTY CO AUTHORS
ADDED. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO VOTE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITSELF
AS ANY MEMBER WISH TO EMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SEEING AND HEARING. NINE
CORKERY THE SECOND DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY CURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS RIVAS AND
OTHER FRONT OF THE CALIFORNIA
NONPROFITS- CARCLUB IN THE
ROLE. CALL MEMBER SERVICES AT
ABOUT. THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS IS THE CAN
THANK OUR MEMBERS ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF ALL. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THE TIME BUT I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. CLERK WILL
READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
CONSENT ASSEMBLY CURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY FIVE I.
SEVENTY ONE OH ZERO HOUSE
RESOLUTION FORTY FOUR I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO COUNCIL SOLUTION
FORTY FIVE I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SENATE BILL SEVENTY NINEWITH URGENCY. I SEVENTY ONE
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY I
SEVENTY ONE KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
MEASURE SO BEFORE THIRTY ONE I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
TEN WITH URGENCY. I SEVENTY ONE
OH ZERO THE URGENCY AS EVERYONE
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE MEASURE
SENATE BILL ELEVEN WITH
URGENCY. I SAID NO ONE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY I SEVENTY
ONE THOSE ARE ON THE MEASURE
INCIDENTALLY. TWELVE I SEVENTY
ONE. DOES WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. AND
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED A GERMAN TO MEMORY
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE GREEN CARPET AT THIS
TIME. A QUORUM CALL HAS BEEN
LIFTED. WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
WE ARE DETERMINED TO MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. IT IS
WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY. OF
MY FRIEND AND MY SISTER IN
LABOR LINDA DAN THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND FIRST
WOMAN PRESIDENT OF MIGHT LOCAL
SEIU SEVEN TWO ONE IN LOS
ANGELES LINDA WAS BORN IN
LOUISIANA AND RAISED IN COMPTON
SHE SAW FIRSTHAND THE MALIGNANT
EFFECTS OF RACISM FROM WHICH
SPARKED HER DEEPLY HELD LIFE
DEVOTION TO FIGHT FOR AND
ENSURE RACIAL AND ECONOMIC.
JUSTICE FOR ALL. AS PART OF THE
CLERICAL UNIT WITH THE L. A.
COUNTY TAX COLLECTOR'S OFFICE
LINDA SERVED AS A MEMBER OFTHE
COUNTY BARGAINING TEAM WHICH
SHE INITIATED KID PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT WORKING CLASS AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITY MEMBERS. LINDA
ALSO FORMED COALITIONS THAT
FOSTERED THE FIGHT FOR FIFTEEN
CAMPAIGN WHICH I AM EXTREMELY
PROUD OF HER- WHICH NOT ONLY
PRODUCED. MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES IN THE COUNTY AND
CITY OF LOS ANGELES BUT ALSO
INSPIRED MOMENTOUS STATEWIDE
LEGISLATION TO RAISE WAGES FOR
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. A TRUE VOICE FOR
ALL. LINDA ESTABLISHED TO
COMPTON JOBS FAIR AS AN AVENUE
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED TO FIND
JOBS IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
ADDITIONALLY SHE ADVOCATED FOR
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF NOTABLE
TARGETED LOCAL HIGHER
INITIATIVE WHICH SET ASIDE
ENTRY LEVEL POSITIONS WITH THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED. THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
OTHER DISADVANTAGED MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY. THE TARGET LOCAL
HIGHER PROGRAM ALONE LIFTED
NEARLY TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS OUT
OF POVERTY. LINDA'S REPUTATION
EXTENDED BEYOND THAT OF AN
ADVOCATE FOR ALL COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO BE IN KNOWN AS A
FIERCE UNION LEADER WHO ENSURED
THAT WORKING INDIVIDUALS WERE
GUARANTEE NECESSARY PROTECTION.
SHE TRULY DEDICATED HER LIFE TO
UPLIFTING THE LIVES OF WORKING
PEOPLE WHAT GUARANTEED TO
ALWAYS RESPECTFULLY LISTEN AND
LEARN FROM OTHERS IN THE
MOVEMENT TO MAKE CHANGE AT THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN FIRST
WOMAN PRESIDENT OF ONE OF THE
LARGEST UNIONS IN LOS ANGELES.
SHE WAS KNOWN AS A STRONG HIS
VOICE IN PROMOTING UNIONIZATION
AS A TOOL TO CLOSE THE WIDENING
ECONOMIC AND RACIAL DISPARITY.
LINDA WAS A DEDICATED LEADER IN
OUR LABOR MOVEMENT IF YOU TRULY
BELIEVE. IT IS THE WORKING
CLASS INDIVIDUALS AMERICA WILL
MAKE OUR NATION RUN ESPECIALLY
AS EVIDENCE AND THEIR DILIGENT
AND SACRIFICE. TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
UNFORTUNATELY LIFE WAS CUT
SHORT. SHE PASSED AWAY AT THE
YOUNG AGE OF SIXTY EIGHT. LINDA
IS SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND
LEAGUE DENT THREE CHILDREN AND
SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN. AS WE TAKE
THIS TIME TO CELEBRATE THIS
TRAILBLAZER'S LIFE WAS ALL
RECOGNIZED AT LINDA'S LOOP ROAD
TO SEE WILL LIVE ON AS WE
CONTINUE. TO FIGHT FOR
PROTECTIONS FOR WORKING
INDIVIDUALS WHILE ALSO ENSURING
WE FINALLY ACHIEVE TRUE RACIAL
AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE. ON A
PERSONAL NOTE I KNEW LINDA. I'M
LINDA ALL MY TWENTY FIVE YEARS
IN THE CITY OF LA. AND MY YEARS
HERE. AND WHATEVER I GOT IN
TROUBLE WHENEVER I WAS IN A
TOUGH FIGHT WELL WHENEVER THE
TOUCH ELECTION. I WOULD ASK
LINDA WOULD YOU KNOW WHAT I
NEED TO DO. MY LOOK BACK AND
SHE WOULD ALWAYS SAY. WE GOTCHA.
LINDA I KNOW YOU'RE GONNA.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WORK
YOUR WORK WILL CONTINUE WITH
YOU INSPIRED US TO DO. TO THE
LENDER WE GOT YOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER JOHNSON AND MISS CARILLO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS I TO
RISE TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SOUTH LOS ANGELES AND HONOR THE
MEMORY OF OUR SISTER IN THE
LABOR MOVEMENT AND THEN THE
SEIU PURPLE AND GOLD FAMILY
LINDA DENT A MOTHER GRANDMOTHER
AND COMMUNITY LEADER WHO BECAME
THE FIRST WOMAN AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN PRESIDENT OF SEIU
SEVEN TWO ONE. IN THE LABOR
MOVEMENT LINDA BROUGHT
COMMUNITIES TOGETHER THE
ALLIANCES THAT SHE BUILT. HELP
KINDLED OF THE FIGHT FOR
FIFTEEN CAMPAIGN WHICH BECAME A
MOVEMENT AND A RALLYING CRY FOR
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. IN THE FIGHT FOR
DIGNITY AND A LIVING WAGE. SHE
BELIEVED IN RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
AND SECOND CHANCES. LINDA WILL
BE REMEMBERED AS AN EXAMPLE OF
LEADERSHIP IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO
LIVED A LIFE OF ELEVATING THE
VOICES OF WORKING PEOPLE. AND
SHE WILL BE SORELY MISSED BY
HER BROTHERS AND SISTERS AT
SEVEN TWO ONE. SHE FOUGHT FOR
EVERY DAY. THIS LAST YEAR AMID
COVERT NINETEEN ESSENTIAL IN
FRONT LINE WORKERS FROM HER
UNION. RISK THEIR LIVES AND
THEIR HEALTH TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE. I AM THANKFUL TO HER HER
LEADERSHIP HER FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE EQUITY AND DIGNITY.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES AND I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF SEIU SEVENTY ONE PRESIDENT
LINDA DENT AND HER DEDICATION
TO ALL. TAKE A SCRIPT. I MISS
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO REQUEST
THAT THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN
THE MEMORY OF STEVE ZURN. STEVE
WAS A DEDICATED AND
DISTINGUISHED PUBLIC SERVANT IN
THE CITY OF GLENDALE FOR THIRTY
FOUR YEARS UNTIL HE RETIRED AT
THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY. IN
HIS TENURE HE SERVED AS
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC WORKS FOR
OVER TEN YEARS. AND ULTIMATELY
AS THE GENERAL MANAGER OF
GLENDALE WATER AND POWER. STEVE
WAS THE HEAVY STEADY HAND AT
THE WHEEL FOR COUNTLESS
PROJECTS IN GLENDALE.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF THE DOWNTOWN
AREA AND BROWN BOULEVARD. MORE
RECENTLY HAVE BEEN OVERSEEING
THE GRAYSON REPOWERING PROJECT
TO REVAMP GLENDALE'S AGING
POWER PLANT TO INCORPORATE
BATTERY STORAGE. AND A
TRANSITION TO UTILITY TO A
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE. WITHOUT A
DOUBT STEVE LEFT HIS MARK ON
THE JEWEL CITY. AND THE CITY
THAT WE KNOW TODAY MIGHT NOT
HAVE BEEN THE SAME IF IT WASN'T
FOR STEVE. AND ON A PERSONAL
NOTE WHEN I WAS ON THE GLENDALE
CITY COUNCIL STEVE ZURN WAS
SOMEONE THAT I RELIED ON. HE
BROUGHT A TRUE PASSION TO HIS
WORK OUR TRUE LOVE FOR THE
CITY. A VISION FOR THE FUTURE
HE SOMEONE WHO COMPLETELY THREW
HIMSELF INTO THE WORK IN WHO I
RELIED ON. FOR ADVICE FOR
COUNCIL FOR HIS KNOWLEDGE AND
HIS EXPERTISE. HE WAS A VERY
VERY IMPORTANT PART OF THE
GLENDALE FAMILY AND HE WILL BE
SORELY MISSED HE WILL ALWAYS BE
REMEMBERED BY CITY STAFF. FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP FOR THAT VISION
FOR THAT PASSION FOR THAT LOVE
OF GLENDALE. AND DECEMBER
STEVER TIRES A GENERAL MANAGER
OF GLENDALE WATER AND POWER. I
WAS LOOKING FORWARD TO SPENDING
HIS RETIREMENT WITH HIS
GRANDCHILDREN AND VOLUNTEERING.
SO THIS IS REALLY SAD AND QUITE
A SHOCK TO HEAR ABOUT HIS
PASSING. I ASK THAT WE EXTEND
OUR HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES TO
HIS WIFE LISA PRAGER HIS TWO
DAUGHTERS. AND HIS
GRANDCHILDREN DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MS FREEMAN
AND MISTER LEE YOU TOO ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR JOURNEY IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
REQUEST THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED
IN THE MEMORY OF VIVIAN LARSON
A LONGTIME ALONI COLLEGE
COMMUNITY SARM A LONELY A
LEARNING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRUSTEE. BOARD MEMBER WHO SADLY
PASSED AWAY LAST WEEK ON JUNE
TENTH AFTER TWO YEAR BATTLE
WITH CANCER. VIVIAN DEDICATED
MUCH OF HER LIFE TO HELPING
STUDENTS AS A FIERCE ADVOCATE
AND SHE TOUCHED ALL THOSE SHE
CAME ACROSS WITH- POSITIVITY
AND ABILITY TO INSPIRE OTHERS.
SHE'S A HIGH SCHOOL COUNSELOR
AT NEWARK MEMORIAL VICE
PRINCIPAL ATNEWARK MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND TAUGHT AT SCHOOLS IN
OAKLAND AND THAT CSU EAST BAY.
VIVIAN HAS THE ABILITY. TO
ENCOURAGE AND EMPOWER STUDENTS
TO SEE. AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THEIR DREAMS ARE ATTAINABLE NO
MATTER THE ODDS. SHE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO HELP TRANSITION
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS TO COLLEGE
AND WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING
TO IMPLEMENT. HIGH SCHOOL TO
CAREER PATHWAYS INTO VARIOUS
STEM DISCIPLINES VIVIAN ALSO CO
FOUNDED THE NONPROFIT. OVENS
ONDO WHICH WORKS REMOTE THE
ADVANCEMENT AND EMPOWERMENT OF
LATINO YOUTH THEIR FAMILIES.
AND OUR COMMUNITIES THROUGH
EDUCATION LEADERSHIP AND
NETWORKING. WE'VE BEEN RECEIVED
MANY AWARDS FOR HER WORK IN THE
COMMUNITY OVER THE YEARS
INCLUDING ONE. FOR COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT AND SERVICE FROM
CONGRESS MEMBER RO KHANNA AND A
COMMUNITY HERO AWARD FOR MY
PREDECESSOR STATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KANSEN CHU. IN A WRONGLY
ALONI COLLEGE BOARD TRUSTEE
LARSEN ALWAYS ADVOCATE FOR
STUDENTS BY ASKING THE HARD
QUESTIONS AND PUSHING THE
COLLEGE COULD DO MORE. AND TO
DO BETTER AND SERVING STUDENTS
HER PASSION FOR EQUITY AND
FOCUS ON EMPOWERING STUDENTS
AND THE COMMUNITY THROUGH
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITY INSPIRED
THOUGH SHE SERVED WITH. AND OUR
COMMUNITY IS BETTER TODAY
BECAUSE SHE WAS AT. AN A
PERSONAL NOTE ON A DAY VERY
MUCH LIKE THIS IN BLISTERING
HEAT MY FONDEST MEMORY OF
VIVIAN IS WHEN I WAS TALKING OF
ANY MANY DOORS HIS SUPER HOT. I
REMEMBER DOOR WAS AJAR I
KNOCKED ON IT AND- TO MY
SURPRISE SHE WAS ALREADY
MENTORING AND COACHING SOMEONE
WHO IS RUNNING FOR OFFICE
LOCALLY NEWARK ANOTHER YOUNG
PERSON JEFF I DID ME IN. BED
WATER AND IT WAS A GOOD
REPRIEVE FROM THE HEAT BUT IN
THAT MOMENT STRUCK ME HOW
PERSONAL SHE TOOK IT AND INVITE
PEOPLE IN OUR HOME. AND TO
MENTOR PEOPLE AND TO REALLY PUT
HER WORDS INTO ACTION OR
BELIEF. CIVILIAN SHE LEAVES
BEHIND HER LOVING FAMILY CLOSE
FRIENDSHIPS AND A LASTING
LEGACY OF POSITIVE IMPACT AND
DEDICATION TO GENERATIONS IN
THE SOUTH ALAMEDA COUNTY AREA.
AND YOUR STUDENTS AND AREN'T
CARTON'S OUR COMMUNITY. LIVING
WILL BE DEARLY MESS IN OUR
QUEST THE ASSEMBLY. ADJOURNED
IN HER MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MICHELLE THANK YOU
MEMBERS. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS SECESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
JUNE EIGHTEENTH LOW FLOOR
SESSION THEIR CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY JUNE TWENTY FIRST THE
FOR SESSION IS AT ONE PM ARE
THOSE REMAINING WILL PASS
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED JANUARY NO FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN THIS CAREER
MOVES AND MISTER LEE SECOND SET
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED.
UNTIL MONDAY JUNE TWENTY FIRST
AT ONE PM WE ARE EXERT.